[Music]
hey tear do you want to do something
really spooky sure
let's summon the white lady
the who
the white lady legend has it if you say
white lady three times into a mirror
she'll appear
uh i i i don't know amber i don't think
we should be summoning spirits
especially the white lady oh come on t
it'll be fun what are you scared
very
what's the worst that could happen well
she could put a curse in us and torment
our lives or she worse she could call
the police ghosts don't call the police
derek
fine okay
white lady
white lady
white lady
oh my god round and white at the peak of
night say my name and you'll be dead by
first hold up
hold up
who are you
i i'm the white lady no no no but you're
not a white person
no but i'm dressed in white i was
murdered by my fiancee on our wedding
day now i seek revenge on all
come on we thought we were gonna get
like a straight up white lady yeah now
that would have been scary she's just a
sister yeah she's one of us silencer
i've returned for revenge and i will lay
waste to anyone who dares to awaken wait
derek how scared were you that it was
going to be an actual scary white lady i
was shook i thought it was going to be a
karen wait what's your name
beatrice
oh my god her name is beatrice she
actually said beatrice there is nothing
scary about a beatrice i am literally
bleeding from my eyes yeah yeah yeah
real spooky why is your name the white
lady
because lady in white was already taken
but that's beside the point there's no
way an actual white lady is scarier than
me can a white lady do this
or this
oh
[Music]
did i die
a scary white lady can't do all those
things but they do do this are you a
manager who's the manager i want to talk
to the manager
[Applause]
she's right
now
she may be scary but i told her scary
white ladies are worse
i legit died quit complaining
[Music]
you